we know the sea calls to you Moana and
we're glad it did it was totally awesome
the way you returned to the heart of to
Fiji and saved your people now we know
exactly how far you'll go but do you
know how far your fans will go we will
go pretty deep into the world of fan
theories to figure out all the hidden
truths in your story there's a lot more
to Moana story than meets the eye you
use a bird to write with check out these
10 epic mamata fan theories that make
total sense grandma Hollis true identity
grandma Tala is one of the best
characters in Moana she is the one who
guards the hearts of taffy T and Tom
Moana is older and she is the one who
encourages Moana to go to the scene she
also has the ability to appear as a
spirit after she passes over one theory
that we'd love is that Tala is the ocean
God she dances with the ocean and she
knows way too much about Sofie tea and
mallanna's destiny the ocean chose Moana
for the quest but grandma Tallis spirit
talks like she chose her granddaughter
that can only mean one thing
Tala is the ocean magical boats did you
ever notice that out of all the boats
Moana could choose from she takes one
that perfectly fits her Maui and hey hey
that's because this boat is magical and
was given to her by the ocean this
theory was posted by a redditor
underwater Raven mallanna's boat was in
the cavern with all her ancestors boats
but it doesn't appear in any flashbacks
also the symbol on the sail is the same
as the one on the heart of defeating
this can't be a coincidence
intelligence required pretty much
everything not just a tickin hey hey is
one dumb bird but he is more than your
average chicken hey hey has to be in
mortal he's at least 16 years old in the
movie he's been with Moana her whole
life and he does come in handy a couple
of times when you use a bird to write
with some people think hey hey is
actually a demigod or spirits sent to
help Moana you'd think the gods could
have fixed someone smarter not the
chosen one
the ocean first gives the heart of taffy
T to Grandma holla
baby Moana couldn't catch it but Tala
was already an old lady by the time the
heart arrived
redditor I stopped tickle monsters
thinks that Moana was actually the third
choice they think grandma Tala tried to
pass the task off to her son
chief Chewie in a flashback he wears a
necklace that looks like the heart of
taffy T but when his friend was lost at
sea he refused to go further that means
that Tala had to pass the heart on to
her granddaughter Moana now he's crabby
brother there's a lot more to Tama Toa
the crab that meets the eye
redditor versa has a really detailed
post about how Tama Toa was a pirate in
his past he also explains how he is
probably a demigod but he's not just any
demigod there's a good chance he is
Maui's brother he knows all about Maui's
tragic paths even though they are
arch-nemesis Maui's dad is the god
Tokoroa which sounds like Tama Toa and
in polynesian lore Maui has a lot of
brothers who weren't very nice we can
totally see this theory being true
Maui's other power Maui might be
arrogance but he turns out to be a
pretty cold good guy and he has the
awesome power of turning into any animal
but some people think he also has the
power of hypnosis Moana is a smart
well-spoken girl but he totally gets her
to say thank you when she doesn't mean
it at all then he stills her vote
hypnotizing humans is definitely
something that Maui would do mallanna is
the ocean did you know that Moana means
ocean in several Polynesian languages
and in all the movie the ocean calls to
Moana out of all the people that inhabit
all the islands why well it's because
she is the ocean the ocean is in her
soul and writer mola to Leone thinks
that once though Ana passes on she will
become the ocean just like grandma Tala
became a stingray a poor unfortunate
soul we love any theory that connects
the Disney movies in one big universe
redditor little Dino's connected another
Disney movie that takes place in the sea
they think that Ursula was the one who
caused chief Dewey's boat to crash her
rage and hatred of humans cost to his
friend his life but now that Triton is
back in control the sieve was a lot more
calmer from Awana to cell on now
how did Orion emo fit into the story the
feeties real power
we know that Sophie T can give life to
people and islands but she can also
offer some amazing magical protection
when now he has her heart he is struck
by tacca but he isn't even burned
grandma's hala is really old and she
dies as soon as she gives Moana the
heart and then Moana is able to survive
a major storm the realm of monsters and
a whole bunch of other stuff obviously
the heart keeps the person who has it
safe not quite human mallanna is a
pretty impressive girl she learns to
sail quickly she survives a major storm
and boat wreck and she can go into the
realm of monsters no mortal is supposed
to be able to enter what if she isn't
mortal several people have theorized
that she died in a storm and came back
as a demigod it would certainly explain
how she is able to do all that she does
she fights all the coconut people and
she swims all the way to the bottom of
the ocean to get the heart of taffy tea
which of these theories do you think are
true let us know in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things look at you next time
[Music]